the turtle what's happening now is
presented by on it this show is brought
to you by texture the texture app lets
you tap into the world's most popular
magazines anytime anywhere using your
smartphone or tablet and the best part
is texture is offering the listeners of
the Church of what's happening now a
free trial when you go to texture calm
slash Joey that's texture calm slash
Joey to get a free trial of the new
texture app the days are back the Church
of what's happening now and especially
me are very excited to introduce you to
hello Tasha calm hello Toshi calm makes
portable devices that spray your butt
clean with water
hello Toshi calm go there and the enter
promo code Church hello Tasha calm slash
Church to get ten percent off of your
order
oh [ __ ] here we go
Tuesday November December 13th the day
the devil was buried at sea [ __ ]
here we go oh [ __ ] the Church of what's
happening now Andrea lo my manly sigh
yet here we go oh [ __ ]
boom boom boom oh [ __ ] the pleasure to
introduce miss Andrea lo hi guys what's
happened I'm so happy to see you
my little brother mr. Lisa yeah hi hello
I was uh we always have the guests show
up just a little bit early just so we
can chat and I was trying uh we I was
trying to find the best place to look
coz I'm always I'm never sure when
there's a like a really pretty girl I'm
never sure exactly what I don't want to
I don't want them to think I'm looking
anywhere inappropriate so I'm like but I
don't want to think like I'm not looking
at her so I have to like look above her
like I don't know I was like staring at
Joey's like the back of his neck for the
student you know where's a good place to
look the eyes ha ha ha ha
but I don't care you can stare my tits I
got no shame like if you're looking at
my boobs it just validates to me as a
woman in my 30s like yes if you catch a
lot of guys staring like as a woman do
like when women get together like that
[ __ ] guy won't stop look I know we
love that [ __ ] the only girl that's not
gonna like a guy staring at her is an
insecure woman who doesn't love herself
if a guy staring at my ass it makes me
feel good about myself if he's following
me on the freeway that creeps me out but
if a guy's checks out my ass walking by
it makes me feel good it's validating
yeah but me my girlfriends were all bang
and we all loved it with all this
going on to a sensitivity you don't know
what you could even say to [ __ ] do
anymore yeah that's true I trained
myself not to look at like 25 of my how
old you yeah how old you Joe that's a
good look like [ __ ] girl for like that
if it's an older guy checking me out
I like do grow up your go manage but if
it's like an 18 year old is checking me
out I'm like yeah I still got it
and don't get me wrong after 25 you
learn how to take a look yeah now it's
like getting punched in the face it's
the reaction to the punch
yes like when you're 18 like oh my God
look at her a side [ __ ] light on fire
yeah when you [ __ ] 50 you were just
looking her ass and go that's never
gonna happen
that's never gonna happen in my life
again so that's the conclusion you have
to come to least you're being honest at
53 I see a hot woman I go that's never
ever gonna happen again
yeah I could give her $10,000 to suck my
dick that's not the same it's not that's
not the same as you know that's never
gonna happen
but why sell yourself short why do you
believe that I mean if I were single I
totally [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you no no
because what I'm saying is not like in
that sense what I'm talking about like
and when you were 20 yeah and you fell
in love in college you went home and you
[ __ ] the three hours away like a
Subway sandwich her skin was really soft
and your skin is really soft just that
feeling of falling in love again just
that whole sensation you and I will
never experience because I was talking
to a friend of mine a bit of month ago
and I said you know I was on the road
and there's these two girls and then we
just told you sometimes you know even
now I could get to it you'll go out some
night and you'll be sitting there and
you'll see two girls they're talking
about [ __ ] that's inappropriate except
this restaurant that was last when I was
[ __ ] weekend but sometimes you know
like right now tonight you go out to
dinner and you sit next to the guy from
Sons of Anarchy who's 20 mm-hmm and some
other [ __ ] underwear model yeah and
they're talking about what they like to
do the women
but you know after a while you know you
get involved and you jump into the
conversation the worst case scenario
next thing you know you're at the house
drinking wine having a threesome or
painting the picture so well they
accurately accurately and or just go
back and do drugs with them you show me
your teeth you know 6:00 in the morning
now the girlfriends call them I know you
had a [ __ ] girlfriend you know all
that [ __ ] but the same like I went I was
in Portland Oregon maybe a year ago I
was just in December but the time before
last having these girls were very sweet
mm-hmm
you know if I looked at them I couldn't
even there's no way I saw what I'm about
to tell you coming every time I go to
Portland something new the first day I
was in Portland three years before two
years before that it was Thursday night
we were all outside maybe 15 people
smoking pot there's a light drizzle of
grains just talking you know that reefer
talk yes we can't wait to go home you
know an awesome somebody knows something
about sex right some guy goes yeah
something 25 and you know the girl was
like I thought I started sex old I
started at 18 and a lot of a sudden all
these people are telling the truth but
there's one woman in the back to us I
gave my first [ __ ] when I was 10 and
it was the end of a conversation like
everybody was like okay we gotta go home
now he's [ __ ] you know nobody bit like
nobody bit if somebody tells you when
you're 18 they suck the dick of ten yeah
she said she was bad that wins the
[ __ ] cake so these two girls are very
sweet they're like what are you gonna do
after the show do you want to get high
go well we usually lots I have to show
everybody good sign mmm-hmm so we go
outside 30 of us and we'll get now I got
my paycheck in my pocket I got an ally
flight but these are the people who paid
for the tickets let that [ __ ] with
them you know you don't smoke with
everybody just smoke as much as you can
right but these two girls are next to me
and these two girls look like if I had
to describe maybe 25
they probably dated like good-looking
college guys okay you know that hipster
Portland hippie but not a hippie kind of
like I wasn't even looking at them like
this yeah
but they started talking that [ __ ] we
like to [ __ ] with just the stupidity
and you know I wants to [ __ ] the guy
your age and he [ __ ] like a rat you
know just stupid [ __ ] yeah which I would
have fell for 15 my cocaine haze take
these girls home and [ __ ] them now you
hear the rhetoric and you're like are
you [ __ ] crazy
and me I'm on the other side I was those
two girls talking you about this and
then you know Bree bringing the party
home and like it's so funny hearing
every different perspective because we
were both in that situation just on
different sides of the coin in a way
it's yeah it's a it's surreal one night
I went the family store and we cuz I
just live on the corner here yeah we
parked in Leawood Park his car we
stopped to settle everything got chips
in the soda and we started talking and I
told him about all the perversions of
comedy mm-hmm on the road yeah I always
think about today what do those people
think yeah wait I I can't think about it
I just have to let it go if I start to
think about it I'm like oh my god how
embarrassing but I just I just tune it
out like if some of them all of them
were women yeah you know hopefully 20
years later by now they have children
and they go to PTA meetings yeah unless
it neg no you know III could see this
one girl still I feel you're on the
dance floor at some Club and Boise I
know it's pretty tame fingering on a
dance floor is pretty not when your hand
is enough posed you're on the dance
floor 80 people in your fingers she's
gonna blind you're coming all over
yourself like what is she thinking right
now
she's probably with a kid playing going
I can't believe I let some guy finger me
too
20 years ago he had his hand in my
[ __ ] snatch yeah like all that type
of [ __ ] if they you must have been you
got drunk went to some guy's house you
went over there something happened you
know you walk out of there and now
you're like what the [ __ ] does that guy
thing today I bet their friends don't
even believe them when people are
involved in stories that were with me
when I was my heavy partying days I
remember cuz I would tell these stories
on air on my radio show I'm thinking
this sounds unbelievable no one's gonna
believe this if these people I was
partying with are telling their friends
our story of last night they're not
gonna believe it they're gonna get
called a liar because this [ __ ] with
like these caliber of like playmates and
models and stuff I was doing stuff with
it doesn't happen so it's like I don't
even know I feel like I'm kind of
blessed that people aren't even gonna
believe the stories I told or believe
the stories people tell about me because
they were so [ __ ] out there they're
unbelievable so maybe you're kind of in
the same thing like yeah joy called the
DA's with banging me on the dancefloor
people be like really not one like I'll
be embarrassed I always think about this
time in my hoping he forgot Mountain
Home Idaho oh [ __ ] is a [ __ ] Air
Force Base yeah I'm up dead I get there
and I'm the feature act as a headliner
the headliner had been there before I
was my first time okay and it was the
way this thing it was like a scene from
a movie when he was breaking it down for
me at Tanner goes up by the way she stay
away from the car loaded up wife she's
[ __ ] crazy
he said that knowing you somebody says
you're crazy I don't know maybe she's
just a [ __ ] maybe she's just yells or
whatever I get on stage I get offstage
she comes right up harder than that you
know I'm the kind of wife my husband I'm
from there and she's drinking let's do a
shot and she's doing hormone shots she's
drinking tequila I'm trying to slow it
down I don't know I didn't know what my
friend meant and within an hour she's
talking about blowing soldiers and all
this [ __ ] again I'm young and stupid I
go I'll take a blow job yeah she goes
let's go right behind the stage you just
said I'll take a blow job yeah I love to
say when there's a
offering [ __ ] she's talking about
sucking dick and sucking balls and how
my husband didn't come for an hour and
we will listen well I'm gonna come in
two minutes
yes let's go behind that stage I'll
never forget I put my unit in her mouth
she's suckling like a soldier and then
somebody yells for her like Miriam I
turn to take my dick out of her mouth
she's a soul she holds on to the pipe
and strike down the flush her feet
dragon while she was sucking that pipe
who could tell that type of story and
I'm not even Elvis like if I was Elvis
or a good-looking guy god Joey that's
tremendous but you know it didn't happen
because I was a funny comedian it just
happened because oh my god I totally
believe it I see it I can I love the way
you paint the picture but seeing that
[ __ ] drag on the floor I'm now you
think that was a married woman Oh
like I wouldn't talk to a married woman
now never mind put my dick in her mouth
and dragged her across the floor like a
[ __ ] like Suge Knight you know but
you live and you learn
and those experiences made us who we are
today you know poor people ha ha ha but
she chose to you know she was a willing
participant in that just that was just
but you bumped into so many crazy people
drug and alcohol journey yeah because
you've got to gravitate naturally toward
each other I don't know how it works if
it's a law of attraction but you end up
with each other by the end of the night
we didn't [ __ ] do an application
process or do a show of hands who's
gonna be you know doing below and
sucking dick till 11:00 a.m. but we
naturally just would find each other
isn't that weird like does this
gravitational force it's so [ __ ]
bizarre and then man you found him we're
so friends that's right and it's tough
to explain to people like no I like my
buddy we went to his airplane it's magic
didn't went to my buddy's house boy 1993
it's like Easter Sunday yeah ever Ollie
he's got like six seven brothers were
all eat and all of a sudden he's
starting to get hammered yeah and he's
got a sister yeah that's gotta be at
that time I'm you know I'm 30-something
she's gotta be 20 something okay
and I never heard anything about her
reputation
she's a party girl she goes out there's
a few beers okay we're talking one thing
Lisa no the brothers get a man and I go
[ __ ] I gotta go I'll give you a ride
are you gonna stay with your brother
tonight mm-hmm she goes with my
brother's probably gonna stay here but
I'll give you a ride home
oh she gets in the car not two minutes
so far she's like listen where we
getting a package at I go tell me that
you do coke she's like yeah I know you'd
do something let's go and we went we got
like an eight ball we go to the brothers
from apartment we get up listen guys I
could take this however you want that
one up there she was my friend's sister
and I went up there with the intention
of snorting coke with her maybe she's
Neve right like I said by myself and get
high and listen to music and jerk off
whatever the [ __ ] yeah listen I go in
the living room and this cook us let me
just go to the bathroom this walk in the
freezer there always is when I turn
around she's got a thought no that's it
she came out of the bathroom with a [ __ ]
I never even spoke about sex or Ted so
let me see you naked it was on this is
the way it was like people just said
listen my [ __ ] around we can play this
game all night you don't have to pitch
me your dick button let's just eliminate
that and get right to the snortin and if
something falls out in the way we'll
just get down you know I could write
this in life no not at all you can't
even imagine that I can't imagine being
Jax teller I can't imagine being a
[ __ ] good-looking handsome guy 28
oh my god I'd be starting coping
everybody you're going 100% it's pretty
crazy
it's pretty crazy now it's so funny
hearing you say that's like my intention
in my experience always was I enjoyed
more getting all coked out and having
conversation all night my intention to
was to just like debate philosophy have
wild intellectual conversations sex was
never like in the intention or in the
platter so when you're saying
I get it when you just want to get high
and talk or you know listen to music or
lose that [ __ ] or whatever it's just so
funny because we write this script in
our head or we think we have this better
idea and it just never turns out the way
planned it's always much crazier in
actuality much [ __ ] I know we got coke
to talk to nobody I did
people were [ __ ] talking my ear off
I'm sure I gave a lot of [ __ ] Leah
beans once they got into history or
anything you could argue about I had a
friend that will rip out encyclopedias
huh I 4:00 in the morning he's so taking
encyclopedias out you're talking about
facts
see now my [ __ ] ego I was the
encyclopedia I was like oh let me tell
you this and I was so sure I knew
everything and it was just oh I look
back and those are the most embarrassing
moments to me that I thought I was so
intellectually superior and that is made
me like Einstein level like I swear I
look back and I'm like damn I with a
dumb [ __ ] is women I did bring home
that wouldn't crack a nut okay we show
you that armpit like listen nothing's
gonna happen here at least T's come on
oh no
there was a grab brought home one time
then nothing happened by 6:00 in the
morning I never wanted to punch a woman
face like I never wanted to hit a woman
with this woman was going down because
she's not arguing with me yeah oh
don't want to do that drinkin I kicked
other people over the enemy you know
this [ __ ] girl gotta go we have a
[ __ ] call a cab for it's weird you I
mean you both are people I know Joey
look you don't do coke anymore but I
never I'm not a big drinker and I never
did coke and it seems like it's almost
like I like you want nothing you missed
out but yeah you like it Sanford too
late to start it's a fine line because
it's like yeah we had a [ __ ] good
time on it but that's right like you
can't like it seems like a good time see
now if somebody came to me and said they
wanted to do color you'll listen that's
point chance on the right navigate I
support you to the right ball yeah I set
you up and you're only gonna do it for
one year a really fair one night since
that's when it goes downhill yeah I see
how many years this when it goes
downhill three years is one
all that fun then all of a sudden you're
not getting hard on it and all of a
sudden you're hearing things and all of
a sudden I went to the bathroom and it
was more coke Devin but when I came back
get up I'm gonna [ __ ] surgery yeah my
face is something else can you quit
after a year do you think yeah yeah you
know and it depends on I think it's like
coke never took me you know what I mean
like I could stop if it was in front of
me I could not stop but if I didn't buy
it it wasn't a problem I wasn't
obsessing about it thinking about it
there's some people though who literally
get addicted almost the first time they
do it and I think that's kind of just
are born that way but so I it just
depends it's person per person I was
addicted to like the reason why it took
me so long to get up because I was
addicted to different facets of it
Oh totally I guess that was addicted to
the copying it mm-hmm first you were
addicted to the copying it you know at
home and you know I'm gonna take a [ __ ]
first yes
you not even doing a line and taking
this [ __ ] because your system is already
off it my [ __ ] was like Pavlov's dog
yeah I would smell it and I was like I
need to go back you know the guy was
there and then different then you had
the thrill of actually going to a bar
like for me my first yeah five years
well actually first three years we're
going to a bar and being sociable yeah
having tons of bad breath yeah alcohol
yes so you're actually we're we've we
probably smelled like shots and you go
out and you talk to people up close all
hot and you think you're high you think
your philosophical well no this is the
ugly side so now you've now we're
showing you the truth no this is the
good side of our mind the first three is
it's great you bring a woman home you
dick works yeah that's your dick works
you come and your dick stays hard yeah
she gets crazy you know she only likes
balls when she has two lines of coke
until then she just has like a limit
when a woman snorts coke they [ __ ] go
all out
when a woman drinks they have like a
little limit don't stop licking your
toes but when they snort coke you put
that [ __ ] on fire like a reset button
it's like yeah now you bring you get a
certain girl and you guys hang
the same place the same program yep you
[ __ ] get high with your friends and
then you disappear for 12 hours ago
look out windows eat each other out rub
cream on each other take a shower do
more it's a [ __ ] process but then
alternate yeah and just like you said
the dick doesn't work the same thing
happens to us loves you on the giving in
you'll do so much coke
you can't even suck dick because your
throat is so numb or the drip is so bad
and that's one of the joys of coke is
you want to be this nasty dick sucking
freak I want to lick your [ __ ] suck
your balls you gobble a dick and I'm
like I can't suck dick right now sorry
and it's like it's a it's a nightmare
cuz you want to be a freak and then you
get to that point where you've crossed
the line and you can't go back it's like
this invisible line and once you cross
it you don't know you crossed it until
you do and they're like [ __ ] my [ __ ]
doesn't work no mo that's a problem with
it now
how long did you get high for the whole
time together years 10 10 har and you
saw the process oh yeah
there's an upswing oh yeah that's a
[ __ ] middle ground yeah and there's a
slow decline absolutely and then you
just sort like this shit's not working
for me anymore you know it's not playing
out the way it played when I was 18 19
20 21 22 but over 28 you know like it
you get to a point where you're like
this isn't the same this isn't fun
anymore and then you just kind of let it
fizzle off for me from 16 to like 21 it
was fun and then I got to the point
where I couldn't talk oh I wouldn't
really the whole introverted or you
couldn't talk wouldn't talk oh I would
talk - don't make me talk just stop stop
Emily says you can't put the music on
let me just [ __ ] live in my head
shouldn't happen uh-huh you go through
all these phases and then you go to a
really deep paranoia phase where it's in
your pocket you see a cop you go home
look you're eatin [ __ ] and also you
like hold on did you hear something and
they could be the hottest woman in the
world and you're [ __ ] paranoid you
can't do dick yeah head somewhere else
yeah it's it's [ __ ] quiet and
interventionist I think of an adventure
every [ __ ] day with it every day
yes I remember something like oh Jesus
Christ I can't believe I was doing at
that time I can't believe I was still
doing it in Boulder at this time yes
yeah well I was still getting high in my
office yes it was such a and like I said
I got more addicted to the action it
wasn't the coke as much as though the
process of it the process of it yeah
it's just kind of like smoking I got to
a point where I had quit smoking
cigarettes right but I miss missed the
[ __ ] thing I missed buying it packing
it lighting all the stocks off you don't
taste the same Oh tastes like coffee ya
know it's like you just get addicted to
the movement of it and the yeah the
process of it I took a half a cup of
coffee now a day three sips I throw the
rest of what when I was smoking I could
drink two cups of coffee yeah bang out a
joint yes I'll [ __ ] sit there for
three hours oh my god for five seconds I
used to love blunts and coffee with a
lot of cream Oh
show your lungs before you even left the
house you [ __ ] yeah it's a miracle
that we're still alive the amount of
partying we did you and me independently
if we added that up it's more than like
entire cities countries nations have
[ __ ] partied and we stand here before
the show we're breaking points we're
talking about how you know I could never
be a hypocrite and judged anybody who
got high
like that that's no it's been there I
know people get high but it's funny now
how I could tell when somebody's closed
to the breaking point like I could see
that like now I'm not from being clean
from being in those shoes I could tell
by people's speeches yes that rambling
speech that the incessant speech the the
stream of consciousness the no filter
the the that you should shut the [ __ ] up
button doesn't exist anymore and we can
relate to it and we get it and so when
we see our friends doing it it's like do
we want to jump in and say hey buddy
stop or do we let them figure it on
their own you know but it puts us in a
hard position because you want to help
but we know better it puts you in a hard
position but I know from experience yes
if Lisa I am who I think the world that
Willie came to me and said you gotta
stop snoring I would love to [ __ ] that
yeah I would have been offended I
wouldn't talk to you and get the [ __ ]
don't call me no more don't [ __ ] come
on this podcast you can [ __ ] yourself
yeah that's how strongly denial I would
tell myself if someone's telling me that
I have a problem it's cuz they're a
[ __ ] and they can't buy [ __ ] that's
what I'm saying yeah I would take a
person that's somebody right now who's
been calling me for the last four months
and all I hear is bad things a babe I
don't see him enough mm-hmm and I'm
scared to call him on the phone go come
on I'll do the podcast yeah and let me
talk to you about what's going on
because your family's calling around oh
he doesn't know I know
mm-hmm but he calls me once a month
drunk yeah tell me about it I just don't
have the balls to call him back and call
a [ __ ]
I can't mm-hmm there's certain people I
could do with there's certain people I
can't there's certain people that I'll
call them out when I get angry at the
situation right yeah it's the last point
this is it I've lived with this [ __ ] for
three years so then I won't say nothing
mm-hmm but I had a friend recently it
was a sister-in-law this kid's been
don't calm me fight if he is hmm and now
he's telling me the story I go listen I
don't want to say this to you we might
not even be friends after this
conversation yep
but I can't have you get yourself
dragged down by somebody he looked at me
with a look I go I love you that
I don't give a [ __ ] she's change your
wife you've worked too hard to be here
yep okay I know how you get now she's
gonna go to this place you're gonna fly
the meter and there goes your comedy
career is that worth and he [ __ ] was
very happy we had the conversation the
fact they even told the girl from what I
said she loved me for it oh that's you
know that is priceless some people you
just know some people intuition you know
Joe Rogan called me I didn't talk to him
for five [ __ ] months yeah well my
best friend's in my life like that there
was a point where you I don't want to
hear nothing dawg
mind your business unless you want me to
rehab drive me and pay for it
that's how I was at that point shut your
[ __ ] mouth I don't want to hear
nothing about my problem do you and let
me it's uh it's a really crazy place to
be I'm happy I'm out of those yeah I
have friends that I said you know when I
when I first toned my partying down I
was I would say to my closest friends
how come you didn't tell me like [ __ ]
you like it's your fault why didn't you
tell me cuz I didn't know I just thought
I was having it on the down-low did you
just it depends on what we're talking
about there's certain things I just
won't do anymore because I don't have
control over but I still go out and
party have a good time
but I'm talking about alcohol and drugs
when you just wake up one morning and
said oh that's it's over well it wasn't
a mindfuck for a year no it was one of
those things where I woke up and I knew
that I had to stop drinking I knew that
all the drugs and stuff weren't
happening unless I was drunk I wasn't
sober ordering coke I wasn't sober
sticking nine pills at a up my ass I
wasn't sober doing any of that [ __ ] it
was once I was so hated on alcohol that
I started making all these really weird
bad awkward sometimes wonderfully fun
decisions but it got to a point where I
realized it was just this moment of
truth it was a moment of clarity that I
can't really explain I didn't pray for
it and ask for it and it was honestly
fear the feeling of fear of what the
[ __ ] is happening to my life
overwhelmed my obsession of drinking and
I just never wanted a drink ever again
it was nuts one day no rehab no
no that's no nothing no no what's it
called when you have effects from not
drinking I had nothing withdrawal
withdrawals I know withdrawals 10 years
a [ __ ] falling down no withdrawal
yeah and Joey's you he has seen there's
only a few people that I had seen me
like that because I wouldn't like to go
out too much like that but the last two
or three years of my drinking Joey saw
what it was like and I had no idea that
I wasn't sober I thought I was sober
when when you saw me falling all over
myself not a lot clock was there we were
at a comedy club and you were you were
performing no yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
this was different
yeah yeah yeah this was me tell you what
this was but that was happening on the
regular and I in my perspective as a
drunk I thought I was fine one time it
was at the comedy club yeah but one time
it was somewhere smaller okay one time I
had a movie screening oh was that it at
a [ __ ] theater
that must have been it that's ringing
some bales next door there was a bar
something and there you were with a
group with the dudes yeah well you
weren't with dudes you were a few girls
when I got there okay
and I hugged you Joey how high and you
already on your way the cigarette was up
in the air the [ __ ] martini drink
there was drinks and then you didn't
introduce me so I didn't know who the
[ __ ] you could have been alone I might
not even know I was girl I walked away
and I went back with those [ __ ]
stiffs and I sat there and we ate so it
must have been an hour okay now I came
back your shirt was pulled out of your
pants mm-hmm
stomach was sticking out I mean you look
beautiful hair was [ __ ] up
yeah you were falling and now there was
two guys with you like I when I got here
she was in [ __ ] of four broad yeah so
will you hug me I'm thinking of myself
what can I do then you wouldn't you know
and the people I was wearing my whoa and
also the next thing you know I went when
I came back God the two guys were there
you just said that was normal that was
normal for me and I didn't think there
was anything wrong with that it was very
very sick and I'm able to see that now
but when I was but at that moment in
I just thought I was having fun I was
told all the time by my friends there
you get to a point where it's like boom
you can't walk you can't talk you're
fine then BOOM and that would happen all
the time
and I it was so weird because I just
could never see it I remember being in
that body but I don't remember not being
able to walk and then you get the phone
calls from the the manager of the bar
that you know oh man you got carried out
again and we don't like kill that drunk
we love you you're our homegirl but can
you not come to the bar again if you're
gonna get that wasted and I'm thinking
back I'm like dude I was the life of
that party what the [ __ ] are they
talking about I've been buying everyone
shots I was like lighting it up in the
bathroom like what are you talking about
I was fine but really I wasn't and it's
so crazy because being a drunk or an
addict or whatever you some people are
when you're in it you don't see it in
retrospect I can totally see it but when
you're in it you're blind to it it's
crazy
my thing was I was never a public guy
yeah I didn't like losing control and
power that was very important then I
grew up in my mom's bar
yeah hello young aids I saw what people
did when they were [ __ ] up live and in
public house you go but in that public I
always wanted I had I have enough
problems public manners and all this
[ __ ] one 1984 I went off I love how you
remember the years of all this [ __ ] he
knows the day he doesn't want to tell
you it was Christmas it was the day for
thirty one day or two after Christmas
yeah yeah this is on a Saturday and I
went to this party I don't blow and
there's a girl that I used to date the
[ __ ] was really good and [ __ ] and she
was another guy and I quote her in a
bathroom
hmm and next thing you know we've took
it outside it became a little public
like people yelling and [ __ ] I'm like
please let me help you like one day you
know yeah and it's like I was totally
the date I was
interesting sometimes I call and I
really get the [ __ ] out of the house you
know only oh god no you told oh we go to
the [ __ ] gym do you go yeah yeah we
always try to you know help each other
what other but you know what I was
totally about edibles yeah pills yeah
especially what happens to people when
they pop pills
why don't you think I always get on you
after I mean we come here we 300 you
know what happened to you I know you got
a high tolerance I know what would
happen to give you a 300 milligrams you
pass out right here you have to this
[ __ ] strongly depends though because I'm
such I have a such an addictive
personality that I might actually not
pass out but end up doing something real
stupid right it makes an indica I'll
pass out because the Teva my eyes will
be like they're all going to coke
paranoia motor but they call my house
but the black [ __ ] we've had guests
get up we had one guest went to the
hospital we have one guest will call me
next and said dog I couldn't believe I
got on the 405 we had to pull over we
gotta move
edibles are different different
different world and yeah I've had some
bad [ __ ] trips out there like I
tell you suddenly go sweat it out
because I go I go League I go to jujitsu
and the first five or six minutes in
jiu-jitsu is brutal because it's not
only you exercise in your body but you
have a kimono on which your [ __ ]
3,000 degrees so that first layer of all
those pills and I had a bulls and reefer
just bust out of you when you wipe your
face you can feel and taste your own
separation that first thickness that go
boom yeah just this warm thickness just
[ __ ] yeah well oh my I just keep
putting all my hand then what comes out
after that is it's pure but that's first
blast now if you don't get that [ __ ]
system that shake those into effect oh
yeah it stores in your fat stores in
your phone this is what people don't
remember valiance issue like that I've
learned the hard way we the 10 milligram
valium your body only uses 5 right yeah
the five milligrams gets stored in your
fat when your liver whatever your fatty
yes tissues for release later on that's
why their time release so you [ __ ]
nineteen valium was drinking all week
and then you go drinking [ __ ] Friday
night it kicks up those volumes dog yeah
and you [ __ ] up let me tell you
something else on top so as we know the
the different drugs that store in the
fat cells so let's say you get sober or
you tone departing down and then you
lose a bunch of weight you get from the
weight laughs oh my god you get [ __ ]
the [ __ ] up when you lose two pounds of
fat because that those drugs that were
harbored and you're in your fat cells
are now in your bloodstream again you're
like high out of nowhere and it's not
even funny like oh my god I'm [ __ ] up
from home fat so like years of partying
just coming out you'd get nasty detox
syndromes I remember I broke out when
after I stopped drinking I broke out for
like three years straight all that [ __ ]
that was coming out of my fat cells it
was all coming out it was crazy I went
through the same thing behind me with
the coke because I Mesa gonna come fool
with these black dudes when I was 400
pounds and I'd worked up with them I
just got clean off the coat when they
would put me the strain you was [ __ ]
like my heart was beating eath man I'll
never forget that sometimes during class
I get all paranoid get hit I gotta be
swine yeah like I'd see stuff like oh
that feels like I'm on coke and that was
the first 20 months of colas it was
twenties you gotta figure since I got a
prison in a Neil and I didn't stop
mm-hmm I finally stopped in 2007 mm-hmm
I went straight from 89 four nights a
week yes maybe once in a while I would
go five nights you know with my
resistance held onto it you know yeah
but I went because I can't like I
totally I made myself a deal as a
lizard's obviously I'm not gonna stop
right I don't want to spend time easily
not I'm gonna stop doing this so
we might as well cut a deal when Isis is
not going to work and will hustling with
doing our job with this not three four
nights a week we'll start off with a
graham and if a girl comes over or
something then we'll kick up the package
whenever we'll play it by you but I have
given myself the green light I got sick
and tired of snorting and beating myself
up for four days I'm not gonna get hired
for that just gonna yeah get high and
get out of your [ __ ] system get high
and get out of your system and
eventually one day you'll you know what
I'm gonna do this [ __ ] mm-hmm it's so
[ __ ] weird it's so weird
do you actually get it out of your
system yeah the body is a miraculous
thing it's very self-healing what we can
accumulate over like 5 10 20 years of
toxicity our body can detox out in two
years Wow yeah what I I meant more along
the lines of like if you keep doing it
to try to get that out of your system oh
the craving out of your system just like
I found out today I was talking to my
neighbor who never leaves the apartment
complex one of those a yeah and she was
telling me that one of our downstairs
neighbors crashed her car and totaled it
because she had like something like she
takes like 14 vicodin yet she's like a
nice older lady but he just takes like
14 I kidding addiction is real and it's
just as nasty as other stuff and a lot
of times we think our doctor prescribed
it it's okay nah doctors are the biggest
[ __ ] drug dealers on so it's like
because a doctor writes it it's still
like it still kicks in that phenomenon
of craving that an addict may have so
you know until you deal with the
awareness and the acceptance that I have
a problem you're really not gonna kick
it because you don't know you're you
have a problem especially when it's a
prescription now how long after your
moment of clarity you start going to the
gym
oh I'd been working out that whole time
I'd been working out yeah because I was
always trying to lose that last like six
to eight pounds of what I now know was
alcohol alcohol I had no [ __ ] clue it
was my goddamn drinking I would have
stopped drinking long time ago in the
first month I lost eight pounds of pure
fat
I saw a six-pack I was like holy [ __ ] if
vanity is gonna keep me sober vanity is
gonna keep me sober I haven't I only
work out once a week I'm ripped and
shredded while
DUS lift weights and not drink and I
have the body I always wanted in my 20s
but couldn't get I was working out five
month or [ __ ] days a week I had a
personal trainer I was counting my
calories eaten all this diet food and I
finally just got to a point after I
stopped drinking I realized it was a
[ __ ] drink that was hindering
my fitness goals it's crazy so now I'm a
personal trainer and I tell people when
they're like me and they have like a
little bit of weight to lose stop
drinking for a month and see what
happens and if they don't have a problem
they'll stop and they lose the little
weight and they're like oh my god you're
a genius and if they don't have a
problem they don't stop and they don't
lose the weight it's pretty is my boy
Lisa yeah every time he was talking to
me he keeps checking me out no no Lee
wants to finger you you don't want to
check these are you from the old country
well my point is he's my brother
yeah you might be the only personal
trainer we might hire he's checking you
out right no Emani
he's going over his budget right now
look at he's on his bank statement god I
think I could fit it right I think I'm
gonna have to cancel that trip with
Paula to Jamaica and just [ __ ] know
it I've just never seen someone so in
shape like I've never seen bad oh my god
you wanna touch the stomach yeah you
want a six-pack [ __ ] my stomach right up
in the muscle tonight I mean I'm I'm I
you know you don't understand it's like
I don't people don't expect it from me
cuz I'm pretty and put together
I'm just as nasty as this [ __ ]
me and Joey are [ __ ] NASA that will
blow me we've connected like you can say
anything it doesn't shock me bother me
I've heard it all I've been working for
you know playboy radio TV for what 14
years it's like I've heard seen every
I was in there were you one morning
[ __ ] skanks rolling that the
chlamydia was Louise snatch your beer
there so at each other one day haha I
think chick came in her feet was so
dirty I couldn't even take in them well
there's two things I hate a woman with
dirty feet in the morning depends if
she's my girlfriend she's been welcome
back yeah yeah that's kind of nice well
you know where it came from your club
without me you got a dirty feet and I
hate when I go to Starbucks for a coffee
shop or somewhere where you have to
stand on line and there's women in the
hair is still plastered from the night
before they got [ __ ] we called up the
JBF hair where it's still up like this
well I think the Vice you left the house
without washing that [ __ ] monkey yeah
it's got that condom juice in it [ __ ]
you like giving that [ __ ] flowers of
war how disgusting of you that's how I
think me too that's why bidets are
[ __ ] good but days are the way to go
this is the truth coming back even
before hello - she [ __ ] time we
contacted them yes I'm telling you
[ __ ] this is the way to go because
before you leave you don't want to wash
your hair that's fine but at least give
some water to the [ __ ] just in case
you bump into a freak at the coffee and
not in the beginning of your day the
middle of the morning of or late
afternoon so who gives a [ __ ] if your
thighs smells like dick I'm saying that
big smells like [ __ ] hahaha let's go
give me a drink I love that we talk this
addiction because it helps people to
understand that they're not alone for
one but two there's hope you don't have
to live like the most important that was
to me what I would sit there at night as
your [ __ ] intelligent you know you so
are you you are very intelligent
you would sit there no you know like we
were I can't see myself so but yes I
didn't want to see myself sober either
believe like and I couldn't imagine you
mean if you would have told me I
wouldn't be drunk right now with you I
would have been like oh no I'm not doing
Joey's show without a cup of cocktails
oh no I don't do you talk trick
[ __ ] listen first off I couldn't tell me
this to his face
yeah if I was still snorting today this
show were the lasted six months and
that's how sad this is because if it was
between me going and let's say my drug
dealer call me and said I can't meet you
at 10:00
yeah I'm going to San Francisco for the
weekend I gotta meet you at 6:30 and I
already had you coming at 6:00 I call
you and go don't even bother
no I'm not because I know that that 637
b7o do you follow me so I'm not taking a
chance I'm not losing my Coco but some
stupid [ __ ] podcast totally that's
how I would look at how can we how long
we move how long how much do you and I
we talk about stupid [ __ ] and Jews and
food and blizzard meat and business do
we talk how much podcast talking future
and TV we talk about a lot of [ __ ] that
would all been eliminated I would never
talk to you about that stuff I want to
come in here we would have done the
podcast and it still would have been
funny when you ever would have done the
podcast it would have been great but it
wouldn't have been consistent we would
no no we started when we started this
podcast five years ago first of all we
did 6:00 a.m. I said the only way we're
gonna start this is to introduce it on
the Airways is sick so it's up by 9:00
and 6:00 on YouTube is nine people will
watch yeah it's hard to get guests
though it's 6:00 a.m. yes yeah people
call that so I have to get people from
the East Coast to call or we gotta be up
before get really high yeah and do this
[ __ ] man by the time you left here I
would go home and eat so [ __ ] ripped
yes ripped
we need Chiba chooses 6:00 in the
[ __ ] morning by 7:00 we'd be purple
in the face what is it well how do you
think I got to 315 pounds out I was
working night on TV and I would go
straight to his house or the office yeah
and at 8:00 in the morning I get a full
jack-in-the-box dinner dude been there
yeah because I was stoned and I wanted
fast what's exactly about dinner it's
8:00 in the morning oh yeah yeah well
I'm sure jack-in-the-box order let's see
we've done this I and I live right next
to it so it's tough um my
jack-in-the-box would have been here
here's I had I had two orders okay
depending on how much fast food and
being I know I want two things at least
yeah so I'm either gonna obviously you
don't go to Jack in the Box to get a
single item no so I mean I'm either
gonna get a chicken mean sandwich and
get like soda yeah maybe like a junior
bacon cheeseburger an order of tacos yes
or I'll get or I'll get the bird or big
one and like a crispy chicken sandwiches
yeah so yeah that not breakfast either
no this isn't that good plus they have
hashbrowns and we're gonna have
hashbrowns overfly you're an idiot yeah
especially when you want to eat and for
people that don't know jack-in-the-box
it's kind of only in our area I get
people all the time from New York or
other places I visit tell me about this
jack-in-the-box thing I hear you guys
mention all the time it's a fast food
that's only in this kind of region I
think there's a couple in Arizona maybe
a few in Nevada
I used to Boulder in 1987 before I got
that su group we'd make a
jack-in-the-box front and in those days
jack-in-the-box used to have a salad or
one lettuce tomato with seafood oh they
have salads but they don't have one
anymore
okay they had the seafood that's
interesting lemon dressing on and I
would mix it in the car and the seafood
wasn't seafood no it was this white
artificial fish imitation painted red
yeah like crab yeah Oh Lee it was
terrible I would drink an iced tea with
tons of sugars like me mm sure there's
one extra lemons it's delicious because
when you're drinking and drugging the
way we work you dull the senses so bad
that you have to overwhelm it with hot
sauce sugar fake sugar all this [ __ ] to
make it taste like something because our
senses are so dulled
straight up because I know once I got
clean I was like oh my god I smell this
I ate a fruit and I was like holy [ __ ]
fruits good like because I
thought fruit was wack cuz I couldn't
taste it now I'm like damn I can taste
the nuances of lemon-lime and vanilla
all up in this mango it's crazy I feel
bad because if somebody came to me today
and said they wanted they wanted a snort
coke yeah I have to look em in the eye
and go don't do it and I would feel so
terrible why because how you Lee and I
discussed it leads to so many [ __ ] ill
effects corrected
well don't effects and the crap listen
not everybody could end up like us no
there's that most people don't laugh L
would yeah that we don't have a story
that we got kidnapped but you know they
say listen isn't this bunch of horror
stories yeah I mean I I we both should
not be alive but like I had to go to
[ __ ] him I was talking about this on the
Maron show one time I had to go to a
boma like I was in Beaumont I had a mic
open we're good you drove to Beaumont to
buy coke [ __ ] dedication I was in
Beaumont doing comedy okay doing comedy
and I run out of a [ __ ] coke and I
call this kid and he picks me up at the
hotel he goes listen where I'm taking
you
this is like white supremacy well we
don't care we'll go anywhere and I went
into white supremacy Vilma guys like I
just saw you in a movie god dammit
what's your name
Diaz and also the room just stopped and
I had 300 bills I gave to him he gave me
the coke and I said thank you listen
thanks for coming you know but just even
that story which went away was comical
you know why that [ __ ] should not have
gone down like that you have to realize
how lucky you are though I mean I've
come out of all these experienced
unscathed I have a few superficial flesh
wounds from some weird [ __ ]
I have no STDs never been pregnant like
it's a [ __ ] miracle I'm alive I've
driven off cliffs I've driven into
parked cars I mean I literally should
not be alive it's crazy
so I think the point is what you said
you if someone wanted to do it you'd
have a hard time being like sure let's
go buddy let me rail you up because most
people don't end up like us
we are the exceptions to the rule I know
a lot of people who did not make it
on the other side I got my teeth yeah my
skin is [ __ ] up from picking it when I
get paranoid I thought I had worms in
there or pimples and I pick up with a
tweezer but we in 1993 I went home is
this heavy for you you're like that's
like cry over it's a lot cool
I just cuz you love him no I love him
but didn't I
I'm just trying to imagine it and for me
the part uh I get terrified at the
beginning I the biggest thing is I don't
want to buy coke and then it's an
undercover cop that's this oh yeah
that's just my a mat and I know when you
guys gone into it I would imagine the
addiction took over that fear but even
for me just to start is too scary that's
why you start small you do have friends
a bumper some friend [ __ ] you don't go
buy it and then you tell you freaking
you get me something you know get a fee
and then one dinner goalie not gonna
just get you're gone it's it's the
[ __ ] guy that you always see go over
the hill sell it to you and next thing
are you going over and you become
friends whom you have a relationship
with other again I've never been
addicted to coke I've done a [ __ ] ton of
coke alcohol was your thing yeah
once you had three beers in you then I
was beautiful I could hear but it was
anything he didn't matter what it was I
was doing this that or the other [ __ ]
that I would never do
give me 15 drinks I was doing at all
whatever the heroin whatever they have
I've never done heroin I've never
injected anything no no but they would
say that you won't do a line of heroin
what the [ __ ] I'm already here at 6:00
in the morning you do a little one I did
it why is that one heroin well here no I
definitely I definitely know I've done
ecstasy pills that had heroin in them
yeah yeah and I didn't care because I
was wasted but had I been like eight
drinks previous you would really be one
of those people that put the ecstasy in
your butt with the turkey baster not
with it no with my [ __ ] finger all
you need is two knuckles you no kidding
and now how long would it take to get
high once you put the ecstasy yes
minutes you don't know when you weren't
high and it's your rocket propelled to
the next dimension it's not like this is
melting yes you got a dance that's why
that's why you have to go up to two
Knuckles if you only go up to the first
one it's you get you're gonna put it out
and if you're gonna lose the pill and
one
you don't want to put it back in so you
got to stick it up far enough with you
know some saliva get it in there and it
stays up past that second sphincter
people don't understand the neck the
anatomy there's two sphincters the one
that's on the outside then about two
inches up there's another one you got to
get past that one and then your smooth
sailin now all you should I really
Hollywood that people would take a lion
ecstasy and mix it with Viagra Oh turkey
basters and put it up your [ __ ]
you can do enemas of stuff I just felt
like that's a waste of time process in
energy I'd rather just stick the pill
straight up there instead of like
getting a turkey baster out and making a
big thing of it here's who I bumped into
a guy mom that she a special because of
coke he was putting the coke rocks up
his [ __ ]
was he kind of snot anymore so yeah I
was getting into a point where I not to
a point it happened from the beginning
where I would swallow a pill of ecstasy
and my body would just reject it so I
throw it up and I'd like be sifting
through vomit trying to get that pill in
there again Oh like this is not worth it
this is stupid this is sick and I would
tell myself I'm not doing it tonight not
doing eat not worth it gives me a
stomachache makes me yack then I get
drunk
where's the E give me the E and I got to
a point where I heard from some friends
to stick up your ass you won't throw it
up once you stick it up your ass
it absorbs so much quickie quick more
quickly and harder and it hits you
harder that you really don't want to go
back to swallowing it or even snorting
it that burns so you can tolerate a
little [ __ ] burn for that boom ah
this is a deep [ __ ] conversation at
four in the afternoon two Knuckles deep
baby all tunicc because that's a shame
too old
ah but you need three loads right I
think whale I missed quaaludes and I'm
in my world you owe me tell you
something I thought about I'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] in my world a quail ooh
is a hit ecstasy is a dressed-up
quaalude okay that's what I that's what
I done I won't it just evolved yes
that's it they just a pill evolved they
said what if some dude one morning said
what if we take that quail a little and
sprinkle [ __ ] heroin on yeah some
other guys we take a little meth on what
if we took cocaine on there what
but a little Assam that was the fun of
it not knowing what kind of pill you
were getting oh my god okay kind of you
know special order I want you a double
stack blue one or I want a red one or I
want this stamp on it but you never
really knew what you were getting
and so you could kind of guess by the
color but you'd take one back ooh this
one had meth in it can't stop dancing
can't shut the [ __ ] up or one would be
like pure MDMA you're like oh I want to
massage everyone so it really was like a
choose-your-own-adventure
because you really didn't know and that
was part of the sick fun it's it's wild
what was the [ __ ] people were shaking up
ten years ago in 1999 means shaking out
2000 that came in water in a liquid
yes yeah what was that she I never did G
but from what I from what I know it
isn't a date-rape drug but when you take
it consciously and with your own
intention it's very much like ecstasy oh
I love you sex is amazing I can feel
every cell in your body you can feel
mine my heart's opened up but I heard
it's very similar I'd looked for it I
wanted to do it a few times but it's
crazy I had this crazy little part-time
friend [ __ ] buddy
yeah 1998-99 maybe 97 it was my brofist
point she was a filthy rich girl mm-hmm
and on Sunday night she would go to
comedy store and I met her through
acquaintances I went to their house and
they she was there she was gorgeous
towering gorgeous big big girl she
became a big size model girl and she was
very sweet and I talked to my scimitar
down he's tall started jacking at rank
you want to do a blast no [ __ ] I think
you know by your looks I didn't think he
did blow yeah she gave me a lob line
nice [ __ ] next thing you know she ain't
gonna come to a house and party we swap
spit I never thought yeah week later she
shadow over she that girl was just drunk
last night yeah she would never kiss me
the next [ __ ] Sunday on Hawaii again
this one ah you're very lovable what you
a Janet Jackson concert together she
would let me I will let me do my laundry
the house I love yeah oh she knew I was
[ __ ] broke but she understood her
father was a manager so actors and [ __ ]
but then she went she was another one
that went from like and you've dealt
with these people that for three or four
months they hit it
mm-hmm they disappeared just like I did
I was hiding I would I would be with
lethal - hmm and like 3 to 15 Li I was
deep already you thought I was going
home I was just with him what do mean
he's not answering his phone at 10:00 in
the morning yeah oh my god what I always
had it planned out from the minute I
left the house she was good for a couple
months and then one night she showed up
but then she wasn't good then no she
showed up with gee I'm gonna water
bottle and we drank it and he [ __ ]
started blacking anatomists oh yeah at
the store we started blacking out and
then she called a cab and we both got in
the cab went to a house we fell asleep
in a [ __ ] cab then we got up and went
into a house probably took a little too
much I think we [ __ ] and then we have
now we woke up making the next day it
was very embarrassing that's it
that was the end of I went over at one
time and then no she's like let's do
some blow and she started to open up a
kitchen cabinets what was in there what
was in there where is this girl is it
time for a relapse
it was 19 it was
everywhere and she was one of those
girls that we don't have sex right away
yeah she would dress up in a little
lingerie suits yes what's your favorite
outfit that a girl can wear the [ __ ] I
want to see it make it I don't wanna say
nothing no candy no like there's no
preference like a french maid a
cheerleader or this or that you don't
give a [ __ ] you look beautiful today oh
that's it yeah show me your monkey
[ __ ]
fights of Chinese New Year you're the
monkey yeah yeah you know I like outfits
you know what you you're like give me
the [ __ ] [ __ ] I can make it I like my
make you want to do a little dance yes I
like that one time yeah you know don't
[ __ ] do like that extent the disco
version there's no I don't have a
problem I always felt like dressing up
was a little like juvenile and comedic
and kamar cycle like oh I'm really a
cheerleader right now little pigtails
and like clearly I'm not [ __ ] 18 and
I think when you talk to me like [ __ ]
shut up I can't see myself through dirty
Freddie yeah that's that big ass little
[ __ ] yeah what the [ __ ] is going on
she's described a blood pressure
medication done together we keep it real
and I think that's why we don't like
that [ __ ] cuz it's inauthentic it's
stupid and it's nonsensical I don't need
someone in an outfit or I don't need
mean an outfit to get me going if I like
you I just need to see you or talk to
you or touch you talk to you for a while
listen to music what's up MA you put on
some music I didn't know you I don't
understand though some people feel like
the sex life gets stale they need that
stuff I don't know I've not got to that
point in any of my relationships where I
need outfits but I do understand people
who do say it does enhance their sex
life so I'm not putting them down I'm
just
for me I find it comical I like some
heels from time to time to get the party
stuff this times I see a woman that
isn't even that attractive but I could
tell by her shoes she's a [ __ ] Savage
yes because if you can walk in with at
that trajectory it means you have
control of all your muscle groups and if
you can walk like that like a runway
model you can throw it down in the bed
it's not every pair of shoe there's your
shoes that drive me crazy even the
flip-flop yeah
the flip-flop when you let the flip-flop
drop in that heel just extends hmm
that's a sexism are you a fat man I
don't suck feet I don't touch feet I
just like to see him if you hear the
Myers pretty feet that's not looking at
if we're bangin and your feet up in the
air and for some reason I see your heel
has got a little dirt on it
that's when the nut blows right there
really oh yeah a little dirt on the heel
is little Irish chicks that's my world a
little dirty I reason they [ __ ] Oh
take the life out of me I love it a
little dirt in today I don't maybe a
little dirt on the neck I'm saying what
the monkeys gotta be fresh well the
[ __ ] I just heard Soundgarden okay I
like something with a dirty feel alright
something though dirty feel yeah I got
dirty feel that's the illusion that's
gonna be dirty but when you take this
sniffing it's a [ __ ] flower you know
spammy but she's got dirty feet I
understand that's where the hope of tois
comes in the monkeys clean that's the
paradox right there but the feet of
[ __ ] dirty Lisa what do you think of
that I like it I also trust me I like
thongs but like by the way I like songs
yeah oh yeah I know well yeah not me not
on me but no I know I know what but I
actually my favorite or actually boy
shorts yeah they make anyone's ass
better that's why boys yeah you have to
have a perfect body to rock a g-string
you can't have a subpart ass and make a
g-string looks look good
the smaller the underwear is the more
perfect a woman's body needs to be to
make it look bangin boy shorts are more
forgiving they create an illusion of a
big juicy ass even when you may not have
one so if someone with a big juicy ass
their ass looks amazing someone without
a big juicy ass is there
looks at me don't looks good magic yeah
and then it's a beautiful one I'll take
it so all those years at playboy you met
all those girls yeah I love I love most
of them you get to know him the one I
met I didn't 18 wheels of justice and
one of the girls that played a hooker
was she lived on whatever the [ __ ] it
was up there with Hugh
oh she lived at the mansion yeah yeah
man I'm a human okay a lot of plastic
surgery she was trying to look like
somebody this is 98 okay the ice cream
man's outside we this is the motorman
heard I heard I'm a female
I keep hearing those bells I'm like is
that the Mexican ice cream that my
[ __ ] rock dude I love me I
haven't had that [ __ ] in so long there's
something about the ice cream truck ice
cream that is just this guy no no this
[ __ ] the best he's got the bomb
bomb he's got the bomb bomb he's gonna
[ __ ] he's got a buddy he's got a [ __ ]
sub banana split which I don't eat since
I was eight that's what I'm saying [ __ ]
anymore
well rock your world a little bit fresh
fruit E's Mexican I love fresh fruit
just came out of the [ __ ] border
yellow banana no [ __ ] brown spots
yeah he gives you Dairy Queen's vanilla
with two things and a pound of whipped
cream Mexican whipped cream butter
everything that's gonna kill your
[ __ ] heart yeah oh that's so bad
charges four dollars and fifty cents I'd
do that side I'll be right back one time
lean down like don't I have mercy
[ __ ] ate one that's how big it is me
my wife and mercy ate one mercy was two
at the time I love this we blast the
banana split cuz that's the one that
used to come to our house so cool it's
the same [ __ ] I love it and
yours look at your supporting business
like that mom business he sells
everything on it you could probably buy
a gun through that guy he's got a kilo
blow he's got ice cream he's got shoes
he's had suits
he's got launches he's got cheeseburgers
kind of guy that dudes gonna rock
there's bubblegum he's got [ __ ]
everything on maybe you know what he'll
come around now it's five o'clock see
that's his timing was always bad like he
come over at 6:00 kids aren't gonna jump
out of the house at 6:30 in Devon
but this [ __ ] comes back at
eight ten thirty sometimes you say I'm
watching KTLA news at ten self take it
to yourself I wish the Mexican ice cream
man was a it see that's what he show up
he'd show up he probably doesn't had six
cuz he knows everyone's having dinner
he's like you know this guy's a genius
yeah he will be funny and he won't ring
the bell after tell he just sits in
front of the house of the effect and he
lets the engine roll and you can feel
his presence oh my god oh yeah there you
[ __ ] I used to see that guy 10:45 I'd
run down on the block of my wife was
pregnant that dude may have lived him
and [ __ ] relations I skated yeah I
would run out there with that dude dog
wouldn't [ __ ] you but his family have
you so how did you manage to stay I know
you said you worked out every day but
that's like that that's what everyone
says if they gain weight when they drink
and I can't imagine that you were that
money said well I was it was like a
hundred and twenty-eight pounds my boobs
were a full full cup size bigger I was a
d all natural so my boobs were very
heavy and I just had a lot of water
retention that shit's heavy man my face
was bloated I was I was still looking
good though but I wasn't looking like I
look now like now I look like me this is
how I'm supposed to look before I look
like a puffed out version of me and I
didn't know any better so yeah you lose
the water weight you lose the excess fat
and boom when I saw you two putting up
two videos and stuff and you working out
and talking yeah
I thought about a lot of people who I
didn't know you gain well no
I know you stopped drinking no you look
like you stopped dripping yeah you can
tell you think and I could tell that uh
but I'm like to see all these [ __ ]
people that got clean went to rehab and
got did jumping jacks for the first time
in their life but no I've been an
advocate here for [ __ ] 10 years know
how they work on everything because of
me I grew up as badly me too even when
the beginnings of doing blow I was doing
[ __ ] and then when I moved to Hollywood
I didn't do dick because that dude died
he did blow the night before he played
basketball he died I said [ __ ] that I'll
never go to the [ __ ] gym you know my
trainer told me because she I was very
honest with everyone about my alcohol
use of my drug use and I would just said
to my personal trainer can I come to the
gym coked out or drunk she goes no come
today after so you can get out of your
system but don't come in [ __ ] down
nobody don't me and my trainer my health
trainer where I like talking about my
drug use and it was still was never
brought up like this maybe you should
not do it at all you know like no one
ever said no one ever said to me once
don't do it not that it's their
responsibility or their fault I I did
the what what I did but it's just so
funny how no one was like stop Mitch
whoa let me say it's really weird when I
first met you yeah next couple times and
this is hard to explain to somebody
because you'll see it for me also
because we discussed it before the
podcast started this was part of who you
were absolutely this is part of your
[ __ ] job absolutely this is where you
were Artie Lange that's who he was on
the Howard Stern Show people expected
him why because we all love a train
wreck that's who I was people loved
watching a train wreck sometimes you
know remember one night throwing a fit I
didn't talk to Steve Byrne four years oh
[ __ ] and he's the nicest guy that was
sweet
he's one of the best [ __ ] guys in
comedy yeah good I am one
one of those cocaine and those cocaine
you know here you know when you're not
on coke because when you party contain
you you I could see the clarity in your
eyes now that oh I was totally totally
cross-eyed hey party let's say if I went
out tonight and did a gram of coke maybe
three vodka oranges at the comedy store
on the way home we stopped and we got a
six-pack of beer but I did that grandma
blow whacked off twice and went to bed
died Tuesday night yeah my Wednesday
night set even if Richard Pryor got up
from the grave and wrote it Robin
Williams and Sam Kinison oh [ __ ] I would
still not do well because I got to tell
you something it would stay in my psyche
the drugs dead oh absolutely
the electrical something that's in that
coke would stay in there so what would
happen I'd say to myself you know what
I'm [ __ ] in the week anyway yeah
another package I mean look another
package on Wednesday and then [ __ ]
Thursday I get lucky you're just being
crazy from just being crazy and then
catching the tail end of a coke induced
rant yeah and look at yeah but not from
my perspective now yeah it was just
[ __ ] that's what it is all those
drugs and alcohol though she is and for
me it wasn't alcohol I gotta stop saying
that it was basically you're not in a
moment it all feels like [ __ ] waiter up
there it's anguish it feels like [ __ ] it
feels horrible yeah it feels like that
but weren't you drinking when you're
doing coke yeah but he wasn't drinking
to get drunk you kind of drink to do
coke to take the edge off right or just
to do something did it become Bhushan
area for me I would just do it to have
something to hold onto
okay so rule no more and they were did
coke before I went on stage oh really
miss Potter 11:30 so you know you gotta
have the [ __ ] strength of ten [ __ ]
what's a dude who walks on coals oh and
then you gotta have the strength of ten
Anthony Robbins to not smoke looked at
ten o'clock
11:13 yeah so what I would do I would go
to the store at 9:30 make sure the guy
had it or stop it oh compadre got a
package - yeah then go up - then get
another package or pencil they both
didn't know I had a package right right
that was a good night when I had to
package for sure if I get on the [ __ ]
pop-up list so there was a cancellation
I go up first
if not I was up at 11:45 11:30 about
let's say you came to me and said Joey
you're next I go to the bar and get a
White Russian mm-hmm maybe - why
Russians I could drink those things like
a [ __ ] animal yeah I just know that
the Kahlua the sugar in the Kahlua would
kill me as a hangover so I'll keep him
down to one right then the next thing I
drink I will probably be like that if I
was driving [ __ ] no I wouldn't [ __ ]
if I was driving I wouldn't do deck
right but if I wasn't driving when I'd
do a little whisky on the rocks and
they're like I'd already have the two
packages in my pocket I go on stage with
the whiskey in me or the White Russian
in me to calm my nerves for those last
15 minutes once things take the edge off
because know it takes the edge of
weightless not to blow well yeah because
that's anxiety that's a reason I got on
stage I didn't give a [ __ ] if Cindy
Crawford had a legs up in the air I
would walk right past her into the
bathroom hey Joey
good Senate okay I walk right past her
bingo on the bathroom and do two blasts
get an attitude adjustment and now I can
come on and talk to people no I was good
I do that would just open up the path
and give me a little self-confidence I
go back and have a beer and then I have
a go home to get that [ __ ] fire
started totally sounds silly but I've
been to the comedy store many times
where the bathrooms are filled before
what would happen you just [ __ ] you
make it happen
that Coke was ready to go was grind it
up yeah I mean it doesn't matter you get
the key ready you have a little bullet
ready you have you I've done it off the
side of a driver's license I mean I've
done it hiding under my hair before you
know when you want to do it you make it
happen
hiding under your hair is a good one
yeah I'm lucky right no but like you'll
notice a lot people have Koch nails and
you're like really is that for looks no
usually it's to just bust a bus whenever
we were guy was on George Perez a good
friend of ours a couple weeks ago we're
talking about he didn't know what uh
what was the word tweaking okay we're
doing many well anything cuz I used to
do cocaine he's to tweak oh really
well tweaking is we can get paranoid and
all that shot I thought tweaking was uh
like a moniker for doing meth but yeah
tweaking will paranoia for sure like I
would go like I was and I've tweaked a
lot on a lot of stuff yeah that would
tell me like you know the worst thing
about that whole evening it'd be at the
end of the night when you had to go to
bathroom and pee and you had that last
glance of yourself in the mirror
yes secondly that last glance of
yourself is the truth that you never
want to face the first time you do and
then you start facing that mirror you
cry in front of it
you promise yourself you're never gonna
do this again and then 20 minutes later
for a [ __ ] kilos cited my dealer to
my wedding yeah yeah that's that's a
smart way it gives you a ball plus plus
he [ __ ] sits there all night giving
it away oh yes please I had my [ __ ]
deal look close to everything and if I
owe the money I'd have him close to me I
tell him to come down that I was we give
oh I was working for guys at once and it
was classic he had that rotation I had a
yard my brother he's still my brother
till tonight I'd make him come down to
the comedy so I tell my 10 guys want to
buy it and he comes and I go I don't
know where they went
and they go yeah but you owe me money
just give me a package what yeah 200 400
is a fun yeah it's all going to the same
place Jay Leno calls will you thinks
going with me to the performance and
believe this cash this cheque of me huh
tell me who who all right give me the
goddamn [ __ ] let me guess
shout out see please dear I'm happy you
came up to let my main man who we met at
the store Garnett owners Chuck you bad
[ __ ] Canadian I love you John
wolf jtj Gonzales Jesse Castro Phillip
rusty your [ __ ] star Tonga muskie
Chris O'Hara Bob a linguist and family
shouts out to Chicago hoping that
shoveling snow [ __ ] Ashley Risa
and Dave repressor nice what are you
[ __ ] nuts yeah I'll be at the to Luca
Luca casino January 6th I hate blowing
[ __ ] smoke up to people's asses but I
gotta tell you now that's it I just got
out of the way I usually don't tell you
people to have two Christmases who gives
a [ __ ] about New Year's you think that
far in advance ties me I said dog nobody
gives a [ __ ] I never bees think of my
jingle bells yeah we go for Christmas
home my family's home Long Beach
California born and raised really yeah
yeah everyone's local I'm a California
girl oh my god I do you were for more
items everyone always thinks that my
great-grandparents are from Ohio there
you know yeah I could even break you
down or [ __ ] you got that lineage
discernment what's up with you Tarzan
how you feeling buddy got planned for
the weekend what [ __ ] go ahead blow
my mind
what is it the ziplining you put them
out of business
okay no you need to defend yourself
because all you lose me is this no I
know I know you know how to do that I
know how to do it yes so what we went up
to this place and I've gone ziplining a
thousand times and haven't broke
anything
Joey you never went ziplining before
okay why you blow smoke up my closet one
otherwise that line before was its
downtown labels I'm forced where the
[ __ ] was that it was like Las Vegas trip
no it's like an hour north of here it's
like it's like a forest I don't know
it's like an hour isn't an hour away
from here you wake the mountains I went
to the mountains and this place it was
really cool had had the zip lines all
throughout the the bigger trees hey yeah
I'm a good zip-liner Joey but anyways
they pushed you off no no they they
didn't have any brakes on it it had no
brakes
so how was one to stop do you get caught
by the other person or whatever they
tell you to do they tell you you have to
pull you're literally like make your
hand flat okay and put it on the so
apply pressure to the wire to the wire
in front of you got it and you and they
and you have to do it slowly because if
you put it down too fast it's gonna go
crazy and you're gonna stop yeah you
want to apply it smoothly and with even
pressure and then harder and harder I
got it right yeah absolutely
thank you you painted a very nice
picture and so what happened though so
what happened was and now and what if
you go to their Yelp page it proves my
point
they give you literally two tries and
apparently I didn't do it like I didn't
hurt myself I got to the thing yeah but
they said I didn't do it satisfactory
and four people a [ __ ] it is why are
they yelping you on your performance at
their place when they didn't give you
proper instruction exactly well let's do
it up rise and I'm simply just give me a
good because we were just in like this
little practice area I'm like give me a
little oh wait you weren't even up on
the thing this was the practice area
we were up in the trees but it was like
it was out of this spot because they do
it I got you I got you
they have it set up so they can send
half the groups home if you go to their
homepage mr. Diaz where they have
Versailles going down oh it closed down
he took the rope down the training you
probably saved some lives I did this you
are a hero man thank you I want to be
honored by the city I am Telling You
your misfortune in that circumstance
probably saved the lives of tens don't
believe that don't blame see I'm an
optimist I'm forever an optimist I
always find the highlighting thinking uh
awkward stories we saw that the 14 years
blackboard radio yeah um just God got an
email got a call truck there's a [ __ ]
jerking off you know it was a slow
dissolving first we were no longer on
Sirius XM then we had created our own
home living online where people could
listen to us live on demand on podcast
we tried to give our fans a place where
they could find us because we never
renewed our contract with satellite then
it was podcast only then it was live
broadcasting certain days a week plus
listening on demand and finally became
fewer shows and then I was one of the
last ones standing and then finally was
just we don't have the opportunity to
keep doing this so we just fizzled out I
know that we are still available and
please like - radio and stuff but my
shows aren't on there I don't think if
they are I don't know and now you're
doing what now I'm really focusing on
health wellness personal training I'm
still doing voiceovers I'm still doing
random acting stuff here there I'm doing
the mr. skin podcast
I'm just staying busy I've been a
personal trainer for the last five years
I love helping people I obviously don't
do it for the money because there's it's
not a very lucrative business taking I
love taking some clay and molding it and
they tried to look at you with a little
Jew look let me look in your smile
anyway like this you take a look at the
belly
like there's no secret everyone said
watch your [ __ ] secret the secret is
there is no secret don't eat like a
[ __ ] animal and move your body every
once in a while
lift heavy [ __ ] and have the body of
your dreams you look heavy [ __ ] I lift
heavy [ __ ] I don't do any cardio it's a
waste of [ __ ] time I go on
adventures I go for a long-ass 13 mile
hikes I'm terrible I do things like
ziplining I go kayaking but I'm not
gonna go on a treadmill oh you do you
just do wait I just lift weights and
functionalize
deadlifts you name it watch ya leg squat
machine I don't go on machines I feel
like machines are cheating and [ __ ]
[ __ ] with you want weights if you
want to get full-body engagement work
the core gets stable everywhere you need
to get off the [ __ ] machine stop
isolating your muscles when in life are
you isolating your quad never do
movements that you're actually gonna do
in real life hey I'm moving something
maybe I'll squat up and lift it you're
not gonna ever sit down and flex your
[ __ ] leg out right so why would I do
that in the gym I only want to do
movements that are gonna make my life
better you should take a leave out a
long bc you I have a full gym at my
place you can come over much work you
the [ __ ] out she puts on tight little
shorts
no shirt is over yes you know saying if
you're lucky if you won't wear on these
so you get the full puts while the
workout oh there's nothing better than a
camel toe stop it while you're working
out you do a thousand push-ups tearing
out I think she might be booked solid
after this podcast I don't know I mean I
I do scare a lot of people off but the
fact is I only do things that aren't
gonna waste your time and I'm only gonna
do exercises that I know are effective
and I'm gonna tell you what I've done
and you can use that as kind of
suggestions I don't force a diet on
anyone I don't force anyone to do
anything but I tell you what I did and
if you like how I look maybe you will do
what I do but it's only by suggestion
the only thing I demand you do is
they'll work we're doing in the gym
three sets of everything you know what
I'm really happy to see you thought
thanks I'm happy I think you know you're
gonna be dead no no
by the time I saw you outside you were
like a ray of sunshine and you didn't
come in here you know bat Playboy Radio
ended what the [ __ ] do you want from me
no we're friends like no no no I'm just
saying like Playboy Radio and then
that's your attitude what the [ __ ] do
you want from me yes some people come in
here though [ __ ] them they did this and
they did that you know what they gave
you 40 [ __ ] years old I'm grateful oh
my god how lucky you know sometimes jobs
Aminta
sometimes I really enjoy no it was time
to pull the plug on that let me tell you
every day so I use I've always worked
for Playboy for the last 14 years I have
lived in Irvine I've lived in Tustin I
went to school at UCI I've lived in Long
Beach I've driven to Playboy that whole
time for the last 14 years what do I do
when I'm driving I'm in gratitude thank
you for this work I understand that as a
female that pretty much is only don't
forgetting naked having a regular job is
not normal people are waiting tables
they're doing side jobs or doing all
this stuff I had a job every day three
hours a day set call time for 14
[ __ ] years I started on Playboy
TV on their Naked News called the
weekend flash I've done tens of other
shows on Playboy TV I've always had
playboy radio for the last nine years so
I've done 29 playboy pictorials for
their special editions college girls
book a lingerie natural beauties what
like you name it I've done it I've had
full time work for Playboy and even I
was crazy and self-centered and like
full of my ego and [ __ ] I always
knew to be grateful for that work now
you only and myself were talking about
yeah I first saw you it was on TV
yep on the Surreal Life on vh1 what year
is that that was I believe 2006 that was
when I saw you that was 10 years ago I
was 22 years old because I remember they
made fun of me for being young and dumb
on that show yeah and I would thought I
was so smart and so hot I look back I'm
like I was just young and naive and
foolish but wow what a trip
yeah that was the beginning of it of
celeb reality that was when reality
shows really took off there was you know
a smattering of reality TV there was
some
memory type shows there was the real
world world on MTV but there was no
celebrity reality shows so The Surreal
Life was the first reality show that
tapped into that celeb reality brand and
to be honest brought in a bunch of
washed-up see d-list actors that whose
careers had kind of fizzled that they
wanted to be in the spotlight again and
rehabilitated their careers in a way put
him in the spotlight give him a fat
paycheck and then they took some they
couldn't have it like you know the old D
special so they thrown a couple of girls
like me some girls from like American
Idol that were young and hot or Playmate
of the Year this or that they found me
through Playboy TV and I filled that
role of like the young hot drunk one
that's willing to get naked and jump in
the pool what was what season was that I
was season six which was Florence
Henderson c.c. Deville Tawny Kitaen
Sherman Hemsley and there's a few others
too but then I did season seven right
after it which was the fame games where
they took all the season of previous
cast favorites so me ron jeremy Verne
Troyer you know Pepa from salt-n-pepa
Vanilla Ice all the characters and robin
Leach put us in a house together and
that was when [ __ ] went down it was fun
it was a lot of fun it's emotionally
exhausting though I always tell myself
I'm never gonna do reality again it was
such a hard experience but [ __ ] yeah I'd
do it again it was fun he has a little
stressful while you're doing it but it
actually made me smarter savvy er more
confident way more street smart you know
I I really am grateful for that
opportunity even though it was kind of a
pain in the ass to do I don't like
cameras on me okay maybe that's why you
need it it's kind of that exposure like
you're exposed to the fear you're
exposed to what you don't want and then
when you can't leave it it's literally
everywhere I'm a ham I love being on
camera and I'd be like trying to pop a
[ __ ] blackhead and there I'm
like dude can I get any privacy like
they are literally on you every second
of the day the only time they are not
filming you is when you're on the toilet
or in the shower it's crazy what do you
think it would be hard to today to get
out to do a reality show like that
because you couldn't have your phone or
social media and internet like know what
that wasn't that big back then it wasn't
that big then but it was still an issue
they do take your phone and you know
I've always been a texter
yeah it would be really challenging
there was no clocks on the wall there
was no magazines there was no books
there was no TV because there's just a
top shelf bar they want you guys to get
a little tipsy and start having
interactions with each other because
that's where the TV is made that's where
the drama is so if you have distractions
phone magazines TV books
you're not going to interact so they
create a scenario where you will get
tipsy and you have no choice but we you
in the house for a month
no leaving no well leaving for like
events adventures oh we have this plan
we're gonna go to downtown Las Vegas
today and we're gonna do this that or
the other oh we're gonna be judging this
or we're going up to wine country they
would plan events but for the most part
you're stuck in that house yeah it was
nuts and that's why it was emotionally
exhausting I just want to call my
boyfriend I just want to [ __ ] see my
dog I just want to [ __ ] know what
goddamn time it is [ __ ] it let's just
drink I mean it was it was stressful and
you don't realize it and people are like
oh my god really that stressed you out
[ __ ] what a quality stress with them
but it really it really is stressful
because you're put in an emotionally
draining situation and you're being
filmed so not only are you like on
camera so you're trying not to act like
you're acting but you are and then
you're stressed out and you're drunk and
you're deprived of everything that
matters to you it's really emotional you
see for me I like I'm a pot smoker yeah
and my pot smoker kind of fills my
personality mm-hmm well you know you
have to assume if you see me
60% stop like no no you gotta was so 90%
that I'm [ __ ] high that man you have
to rate what grade right how far deep
I'm into my mind [ __ ] right you
understand me yeah I met a former stoner
I'm gonna tell you something man when
I'm deep into my mind thought you don't
want to be filmed what what what the
[ __ ] is Italy well I didn't know if you
only give it Captain Kirk enterprise how
many times you say something and then
Olli was gonna bother me with this phone
you know this answer don't do it leaves
a smart guy whether you thought you're
the [ __ ] you you run this [ __ ] I just
come in and [ __ ] around with you
and he'll I could see him look at me
it's because I'm deep three days and we
just put in 300 milligrams of [ __ ] dude
tar and [ __ ] it the transmission fluid
let me tell you I'm one of those people
that I look at the label of everything
that's some quality [ __ ] right there
no that's made with you and the lady
that's somebody nobody tells you nothing
but there's never any hood you know
where that shit's [ __ ] people up and
they sell everything [ __ ]
it's not name she does know it's got oil
yeah it's made with this [ __ ] law I'm
saying they knocks you over the top
we're the only two animals that can eat
300 milligrams not too many people could
eat a lot 300 milligrams that [ __ ] yeah
and it was so oily you know how we said
earlier how the THC and other drugs are
stored in your fat so the oil is what
exacerbates the high so when you get
something hello oily like that it's
gonna hit you hard it's gonna hit you
clean it's gonna hit you fast tomorrow
go to jiu-jitsu I love that and after 10
minutes of me [ __ ] does the bottom
sweat and anxiety sweat yeah tsunami you
know tomorrow I go to jujitsu I'm
jumping rope to warm up I'll do some
kettlebells to warm up I'll stretch my
shoulder that training functional they
have my tactical fitness - wow that [ __ ]
I want to come I'll warm up over there
and then at 12 I jump into the jiu-jitsu
doing the warm-up I'm having a [ __ ]
mental break there because I can't
breathe right I'm on my back I'm gonna
set up some little jumping jacks I'm
doing squats but I'm breathing out of my
nose to the movement I just keep telling
myself to breathe I do that - I breathe
- the cadence and the rhythm you have to
do yeah and next thing you know you're
stretching it's the end of the warm-up
and right there when I go like this in
my hands
Oh wipe my hand that first layer of
sweat that's coming out of you guys oh
my cast and then you wipe it on Giggy
and from there and everything changed
and then another batch comes out later
on
that's from 1988 that was [ __ ] me a
foot [ __ ] that's an old resources then
you start it's amazing I love all that
[ __ ]
I always knew at a young age for me
after I did blow
I didn't want his sweat cuz I didn't
want to bother the heart yeah so jazz
always have had miso soup and sushi I
was gonna be okay that okay that was my
little mindfuck that was your healing
reviewing how long did it take you to
clean my system after you stopped
drinking it mm-hmm take you like six
months to realize what you had to
realize no I knew where you want to
shaky ground those six months I was
emotionally unstable I would call you
not me could anybody at that time yeah
Vince you go have a drink no you were
good you were gonna together I was
immediately you are walking on eggshells
because you are no nothing bad is coming
no I am so funny I had my last drink on
March 3rd and I was like oh [ __ ] st.
Patrick's Day yep maybe wait till the
18th I was talking to my friends and
they're like just don't go out it's just
another day you know and there go pickle
yeah but it's a holiday and it's a
drinking holiday they said [ __ ] every
day to you was i drinking holiday you
didn't need an excuse you don't need an
excuse now just don't go out and I
actually went to Vegas with Playboy
four weeks into my sobriety of my not
drinking alcohol and I was really scared
not that I would drink but that I
wouldn't know how to have a good time
because I had never been an adult having
fun without booze and I actually went to
a club and I started dancing just sober
like not even a pot cookie or anything
and I was like oh my god it was another
moment of clarity I can have fun and I
can dance like a nasty [ __ ] beast
without alcohol and to me all these
little steps were validation that I
didn't need that [ __ ] it was I have a
very unique story at a very high
rock-bottom
you know I didn't have to go to the
depths I didn't end up on Skid
[ __ ] row I didn't go to rehab I
didn't have like some white light
experience I just woke up one day sick
and tired of this [ __ ] and I really was
like I'm done it was it was I think was
a miracle because like I couldn't stop
before I tried everything switched
alcohols tried to not drink you know
tried to read self-help books try to do
like master cleanses and nothing worked
and then one day I just didn't have to
drink anymore I can't figure it out
so I'm just writing amazing how it
clicks it clicked it clicked hard it
clicked profoundly and that's what it
was nothing was ever profound before I
was like [ __ ] I've been lying to myself
I quit in November and I was thinking
about if in November or October before
yeah but this happened I kept getting
electrical shocks yes me too
I knew it yes I kept thinking this house
to him it was these jolts of electricity
then I got a call from a buddy of mine
got arrested so he goes hey man I'm back
in Jersey we start talking like oh so
you still get nothing it was all
absolutely it was a hello knocking on
the door we're gonna get $7 bags that
tremendous ever since 9/11
$7 $7.99
do you know that not even a week later
in my mailbox
written with a kid that was three my
name Jose Diaz whatever he [ __ ] sent
it to me three little sevens that's
great they like nothing like it was
nothing I did a couple bumps and the
Monday I got sick and then it was funny
because I would do it and not get haider
and not get snort coke during the week I
stayed off coat because I would do
heroin one night a week I'm so glad I
never tried heroin I'm so glad my brain
not at the end and take a look cause
something happened yeah something
[ __ ] yeah this ice 10 September
I started doing little coke again but
then I went to Jersey and I was whatever
all I mean it was a hotel room yes that
was my whole thing yeah as soon as I did
calm is I got a hotel
that was it that was ma'am I couldn't
get high here I was under 2 million I
see yeah and I felt the same way because
I traveled so much with my work to the
hi I was doing in LA was conditioning by
you know I keep your dreams I yep
it was just maintenance hot yep these
just maintenance highs like this was
when I was here I would just do like
Graham or 40 hours worth when I went on
the road that's what I could go [ __ ]
nuts and that's how you picked up
victims that were pretty good you picked
up other crazy people hmm hmm three days
ago I got a facebook for my girls I love
to death I bought in fact I talked on
the phone she Facebook me the Tommy she
lost my phone number if I could she gave
me her number for me to give her a call
I called the back and we giggled for a
few minutes she's married now you know
but I got off the phone and she's one
that you know I ever think about
I met her when she was a young girl
mm-hmm ala comedy club and she was a
waitress mm-hmm but one day I was
looking for a package and somebody came
to me and said talk to her no that's
like what are you [ __ ] kidding me her
boyfriend swings [ __ ] coke so I had a
crush on you know she was beautiful
wasn't gonna ask us [ __ ] Alesi and one
night she came to me she goes if you
ever need something let me know and okay
so she gave me some [ __ ] one night that
was just mind-boggling
it was top of the [ __ ] worth [ __ ]
this is 19 oh my god talking about this
bomb this was shiny low-cut still had
the flakes all that stuff and I took it
back tomorrow
we [ __ ] washed it up I whacked up at
3:00 in the morning
I'm checking off uncontrollably there's
no porn and something I don't let me
call them and see right get more this
yeah I call her up get it while the
getting's good
yes who delivers she does so he would
wait in the car and she'd come up and
give it to me that happens about four
times for one that I know is he gonna
show me those titties
and she was like no okay and then they
went from titties to show me your monkey
to let me your monkey while the
boyfriend was in the car wait no what
did his ass think you all were doing for
15 minutes the wall no no no I come in
and I have nobody in her [ __ ] two
minutes
hear that bomb myself Oh got you it was
a stranger knocks on your door and let
you eat that [ __ ] brings you coke I
wouldn't even at the beginning I
wouldn't even ask her because I just
come when I was eating a [ __ ] [ __ ]
love this is the feel that every man
want she was just not in the hotel room
coked out of her mind
big brushy come in while she was giving
me the coke I'd be giving me the money
I'd be taking off her pants and [ __ ]
pull him down and eat a little monkey
I'd wipe off I'd have come and then she
leave and that was and that happened how
many times do you think 10 20 that
happened like 10 times
boy I got endurance then she spent a
look at my boss and it would take weeks
we freaked in 8 minutes total eight
minutes she'd be right that back
downstairs dressed that's [ __ ] insane
woman you had it down pat this one on
for maybe every for three years every
time I went to big table at home he had
no idea down the car no he didn't even
give a [ __ ] at that he was just a
delivery girl he was they would stay up
on my delivering ball see now I totally
know that everything you're saying is
100% so we lived this life something
we're like there's no way that you were
down to a minutes exactly she was up
there you were glam BAM done she was
back in the car I'm like yeah no first
door first door I need six like right
now today I go to the wheat store guess
what when I got a weed store every time
I go over we'd stop by my house there's
a car in front of the weed store what
somebody's sitting there rule number one
you never park in front of the drug
dealers house yeah well I can't film
your partner from the drug dealers house
okay rule number two if you deliver to a
hotel room you better stay in here 15
minutes
so they'll know you're a coat deal yeah
you just don't walk in through every
time she walking to my room she bring up
two videos she'd bring up four books
she'd bring up a gown the milk she'd
stop at the gas station and get me a
gallon of milk or protein shake or
something for the morning she was very
[ __ ] smart
okay so anybody [ __ ] knows that he
wants to be in Vegas I don't gotta live
in Vegas then I would call him yeah how
good he was I would call him and no
matter what time he'd get up to my hotel
room yeah
to security he knew everybody and he'd
sell you the eight ball plus for an
extra twenty you gotta come down package
to Vikings of Valium [ __ ] paint
bright anyone ever tell me about gotta
[ __ ] come down I had to have a
pornstar tell me you needed xanax or
something at the party stuff you just
had to stay up for two days or feel or
peel an orange and take the [ __ ] skin
out and put the peel in your mouth this
is all Colombian type [ __ ] yeah take the
orange you cut it you rip the inside
time you put that peel over your teeth
look that's fine fiber that white fly
but you're out within 15 [ __ ] minutes
does that work for non-narcotic come
down like can I use it as a sleeping no
that works for [ __ ] I just did to
eight ball socket 18 Cox I still got
sperm dripping out of my [ __ ] want me
to go to sleep too [ __ ] forgive the
pain it's Sunday they don't wake up on
Tuesday don't give it to Grandma to help
her with her inside
no no you know III I I get up every
morning man and I my feet touch the
floor and people must you know you
people at home listens they should think
I'm crazy but I swear to God I give
thanks I give thanks for my wife my
daughter well I give thanks for the most
important thing that I stopped putting
that [ __ ] up my [ __ ] nose straight up
I really do and guess what guys I know
you guys know enjoy [ __ ] you you're a
hypocrite
I had a lot of great [ __ ] up
absolutely I had a lot of great time
though I told the story on Joe Rogan my
girl on Facebook she had a black baby or
people torching off of my naked bud so
when we were kids first off I never
slept with it she didn't even like me
growing up she dated this dude so she
didn't really talk to kids her age and
she didn't really really like our circle
she thought were jocks or whatever but
the word was a [ __ ] didn't get moist
sir but he called horrible everybody
called the Fairview New Jersey because
everybody knows Fairview's a dry hump
and then was a puss and then then they
the rumor got out that she she had like
VD let's say her name is was what's your
first name again
Andrea Amelia Andrea okay that cookie is
strong and very common for over a decade
let's say Andrea we study start calling
a song from ac/dc she's got the jacket
so he started calling my hand reject
write to a fate andrea jack [ __ ] you
I have no diseases this one I'm for
about a year then she disappeared and
she disappeared everybody disappeared my
saw out one night but the talent of the
story is or coked-up it's 6:00 in the
morning we just robbed her you just
robbed her we didn't rob her we just
robbed the guy she was playing nanny
tonight she look after his dick - and
when a hotel room a dirty hotel room
others in Jersey other Anne Tolley
no we busted into the hotel room was
sitting there we got booze she takes a
look at me and she goes before we do
anything I just want you to know without
gonna have any sex I go fine and in
about 20 minutes and she goes you know
what I've been thinking about it ha
maybe we will do a little something but
she does you have to guess the color of
my underwear and I'm like and I'm
sitting there I'm like oh my god I'm
horny I'm cooked up only either [ __ ]
I gotta go for broke and I go red and
she goes green but close enough ha ha ha
that's how crazy she was holy [ __ ] like
I would never have that type of maybe
1820 Christmases ago I'm lonely I don't
have a girlfriend
hmm this is half a [ __ ] chick that
lives in my building she lives around
here
she lives in Ralphie she'll is it
Ralphie maze building okay yeah you know
she's got the fake tip why is that funny
why is that funny I just get when he's
gonna have a chick I started thinking
about what is it a Kardashian what's his
name Kanye West
no I Scott no the father mother yeah
Bruce yeah Caitlyn Caitlyn what it was
for woman who said half a woman I know
you said the same as frail how was her
she was pretty she had a daughter that
look like listen to this she had a fat
little daughter and she had a mustache
no we're serving Pavarotti the opposite
yeah Pavarotti
I mean heard of Pavarotti reference in
20 years she look like Pavarotti
cover obviously no trouble Pavarotti
looked just like she never knew right
this is [ __ ] crazy this girl is
pretty right for a dude yeah okay so now
I'm about 36 yeah I'm single I'm [ __ ]
broke she was just like Pavarotti just
like the far away are the images yeah oh
my god is just a show all right like the
white one like you see where the one
that says Pavarotti yeah yeah that one
like that right that's a no one oh yes
anyway forget about that was a big name
we gave that's cute mom was really cute
I mean
unless you're [ __ ] [ __ ] you could
tell it to mom one on the other side of
the fence I'm talking the time yeah you
know when we what does that mean you
could tell that she had been around the
corner she a boy she it wasn't her first
rodeo she went behind the cabbage
everything liked it it was just you
could tell she just had a look to her
one night she got drunk with a bunch of
people and nothing happened but I could
just tell by her body room I never this
respect to the shared daughter in the
building whatever and it's about
Christmastime it's about the holidays
yes it was around the holidays and I was
out all night I was my Josh Wolf's house
around their home and that building
there we used to have like a cocaine
Network up on the third floor there and
I did coke all night there and I go back
to my buddies to watch football mm-hmm
I'm coming down off the coke mm-hmm I
got a little bit in my pocket which
means I'm still ready to go oh yeah oh
the bum that the Pavarotti woulda shot
myself I bump into the mother and guess
what what she was our land before she
even little taste so I gave him a place
in the whole way I gave her whatever I
had I've got a couple bumps with it
mm-hmm and she goes can you get more
like oh sure when I gotta go it's time
to Molly and I know you have a car born
we took a ride home we come back we go
six leave we do a couple more pumps and
she's saying that her apartment says
give another creeps
Oh she goes do you mind if we go for a
walk so before we go far over let me see
if I can give her a stabbing right here
in this fairway you know us dog what's
that it was I know man listen the
building's quiet
we need this town all right here I'm
gonna stay away all right what the [ __ ]
but you sit on when you pick up your leg
I eat your ass but like dig it right and
right there is there any ones whose ass
you don't eat first
well whatever [ __ ] has the same whole
vicinity yeah you gotta sell the ass
because that gets them a little bucks
total think you can eat my ass
exactly he's gonna hook it up and then
you show them the coke rock tell them to
put this in your [ __ ] to really get
the boys telling the more than you love
ha I'd tell you the morning we got to go
deep into the hemisphere yeah and your
ass because that's the end of your night
pretty soon you got a man with a big
bang oh my god I get you I don't know
what happened that's what we do next
thing you know this is crazy I'm telling
you this [ __ ] you know we kind of [ __ ]
around a little bit but when I pull out
of her mouth I come up at Christmas G's
or at least you oh geez that's the one
she was gonna wear for Christmas morning
or this [ __ ] wasn't me once you have all
right before and they have 19 it was one
of those cocaine comes 20 hours of blow
its effect oh no it's not and it's curly
yeah she goes in the [ __ ] house aren't
you glad you don't know that's the end
of that yes took three nights later I'll
compadre waiting the cop can you just do
your little tiny outburst of
exasperation into the mic my people have
taped them two three nights later it is
Christmas Eve I'm never forget I was at
the Comedy Store
that's how lonely I wasn't with economy
so I got a compiler the cop there about
the clothes that are compadre and I'm up
there trying to get blow from one of the
waiters and I'm sitting outside waiting
to come out and who comes walking
towards me but the girl with the jeans
with the come she didn't have mom and
her boyfriend Asti [ __ ] I love you
this dirty [ __ ] doesn't even look at me
and the boyfriend stays no you can't
make eye contact it was guilt and he
goes I don't know what happened between
you two guys
yeah well whatever happened has to get
cleared up she's not very happy with you
right now
oh thank it's your [ __ ] fault well no
no he didn't know I came out of pants ah
he just said about the drugs about he
said to me no I don't know what happened
between you two thousand David she's not
very happy
I go What did he say what is even a a
believe like I don't even know no one
what did she say any goes I don't know
you guys are partying you guys sometime
how an argument awesome but I felt like
saying no I came on a [ __ ] leg
you know why was this this is the type
of [ __ ] that couldn't happen if but I
also wouldn't a kidnapped Arabella right
I also wouldn't guard the prison I also
wouldn't have done a lot of [ __ ]
things well I knew I wasn't end up in
prison to do something I can't worry
about that one you meant to be something
you meant to be something that's it
but it's amazing the journey it did take
me out you know like that I'm with you
man I could write to like right now I'm
writing about I'm trying to write this
first three chapters to sell a book and
I'm on 1984 oh you're going
chronologically like to sell this I
gotta go from 79 to about June of 85
before I bust out with this so I haven't
even jump over like anyone anyone was
dying
mm-hmm so I said let me go over to 84
cuz any foot was a hard hit me and I
mean I'm up to like June of 84 and
there's times I gotta stop because this
is one of this pattern started mm-hmm
this pattern started in 84 so that's
when you think you cross that invisible
line was 84 Duke it became something
else
yeah it went from being fun Friday and
Saturday into now habitual to be a funny
one from Friday and Saturday a grand a
gram I would do a gram bump I don't know
okay I'm talking about its mean you're
always I was what was seeing each other
as they said in the eighties yeah I
wouldn't pick you up you knew you were
gonna spend the night at a hotel room so
we both to the gram we did a gram from 8
o'clock to 3 at the bar Wow a half a
gram then the other half back at the
hotel room or we're getting naked and
all that
[ __ ] mm-hmm and it was fun on top of
that if it wasn't just you me for sex at
least we'd go back and you talk to me
Ann and your brother would come on he
talking it whatever yeah it was
something it was fun we drank we
listened to music and then after that
even in Colorado in 83 I was 19 it was
still a Friday night thing mm-hmm and
there was no paranoia once it was done
the worst thing he did was jerk off on
your leg and you went to bed that's it
you welcomed him when you felt shitty
about jerking off a she's maybe you
should have a girlfriend of the date but
that's as far as it went
it wasn't your rent money it wasn't
gambling money when I went back to New
York in 84 it was there taken over
everything
mm-hmm and like I said a thousand times
people like you would come up to me and
go Joey just not a coincidence can you
move some of this yeah Lee likes it my
friends like like the commies but you go
hold on a second you'd make a call and
next thing that your boyfriend be at 20
minutes late he's like listen guys it's
usually 19,000 for a kilo I'll give it
to you for 17.5 hey we don't have no
money don't worry about it we'll pick it
up in ten days because nobody won that
their house normal that's crazy because
[ __ ] scary man people were coming to
you and going hey Andrea do me a favor I
got 50 pounds of coke and you move in
you're like I know Ron Jeremy yeah in
the eighties it was born you know like
you could say I'm that's what I would
say I've done coke with you I'm looking
care right that's what I would think of
myself I go well 1985 84 I know Ron
Jeremy maybe he could bring it into the
valley and give it to some of the
[ __ ] girls but are they gonna take it
to the mansion like well if you listen
to read these stories that people are
saying now from the mid eighties they
were buying half kilos it's all about
Hollywood nuts it's them Don Henley yeah
Don Henley from the Eagles that book
with the hooker I just seen an expert
cuz I just mentioned that
when I first moved to town the hot book
in town is you'll never work in this
town anymore written by an ex-hooker who
told all the stories all of them was Don
Henley that's nuts
Don Henley would get five girls four in
a row and bend them over and just switch
and just eat their [ __ ] and then do
coke and they'll eat their [ __ ] and
do come but they had to be bent over
although he would even look at their
faces how [ __ ] crazy is that pretty
much that sounds like Tuesday to us
right no that's that's that's that's yo
no it is it I don't even talk to me
ladies but no but what kind of woman
like I would be the person eating the
[ __ ] but what kind of girl would let a
guy bend her over and line them up like
that I'd be like you don't want to look
at my facebook you I'm out I'm so much
more than just a snatch it's like it's
like you pick some with a crazy ego and
you pick someone with no self-respect
you put them together it's a perfect
match ya know that's what it was yeah
crazy eagle I mean it was a [ __ ] guy
from the Eagles I mean I can't [ __ ]
blame him
no I mean it I can only imagine what it
would be like to be that famous and have
people just throwing themselves at you
all the time I mean she had Jack
Nicholson there she had a bunch of
people in there but the story she was
talking about that that there when she
had gone to the Eagles house she was
there for three days and she knows for a
fact that like four ounces with the
limit that's me I couldn't do an ounce
no week by myself I mean I do it don't
get me wrong it's going down I just need
to bump into the right victim right and
the right hotel with the right [ __ ]
circumstances and you're in like flint
yes yes I mean it's a lot so you
wouldn't afford code no you can't horde
coke that's the thing you want you think
you're going to but you you you can't
there's no self completely hoarding it
at once so like you've spoken about like
you didn't like sharing right you just
said if you had an ounce you'd have to
share and if you've spoken before but
like snoring against the clock like why
like why not just save it for later that
night like why do you have why do you
feel like it has to get done on a hurry
it's an inner [ __ ] obsession yes if
it's there it's gone there's no saving
nothing for the mouse
no and my world does nothing save for
the mouse vet in 27 years I could count
on one hand oh my how many nights I
passed out and left a gram or a line of
coke with two lines
I didn't stopped or it was over and how
long did you cook 27 years and how many
nights a week do you think four or five
you thing and the left of the coke was
gone then you start walking around
everywhere you were in the house looking
for little spots of white powder on yes
yes oh my god clean up the straw and the
straw has a rock in there that's [ __ ]
huge that saves you for half out and
then there was an organ there was a
little bit yes a half hour in between we
twenty minutes in between bumps and if
you're an animal like me it's every ten
minutes yeah and it's so funny too cuz
you look at the clock and like I'm gonna
stop at 12:30 I'm gonna stop at 12:40
I'm gonna stop at 1:00 I'm gonna stop it
like you can't [ __ ] keep your [ __ ]
straight willpower is not a thing so
that's why for me like I'd always get a
little bit so I knew when it was done
that was it I couldn't get more because
once you start you really can't stop and
this is even coming from me who was
never I do not think I was a cocaine
addict at all I just partied a lot but
situationally you just can't stop you
can't hold on to it
no for me it was once I got it it was
gone
yeah there was no saving it for Tuesday
no no nothing guys [ __ ] crazy I'm so
happy nine years isn't that blessing
nine years have not done a lot of coke
man I don't miss it no are you your life
is so much better without it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] it was like in my mind
like I compared to my drinking it was
like I was almost a slave to it
my life was revolved around that [ __ ]
where am I gonna get it Who am I gonna
drink it with I wasn't able to drive or
go certain places because I was too
[ __ ] up I couldn't go to events like
that it was just ruling my life why I
said to you at the beginning
yeah that that part of my life is I
could not see even filet no even today
if I said to you guys you know what
[ __ ] I'm getting divorce my wife is
taking the baby to Tennessee I'm gonna
take the house whatever I couldn't see
myself going back I could not see myself
doing blow no what a comedy girl at like
28 and Here I am 54 55 you know in the
house because I think I'd get a heart
attack yeah I'm so scared at this point
that for me it's not worth it no you
know to that if you started you couldn't
stop again you'd have to go another 27
years unless you died first it's like
you know how low it will take you so why
even take that risk you [ __ ] had all
the fun you've done it you're done well
what's on bas Rutten er they people
known to Spain you understand the
addiction continues to grow just cuz you
drinking yeah the inside little
addiction that you had a drinking still
grows yeah as soon as you decide you're
mine you know what I got this I'm having
a [ __ ] beer that's it first
being your office [ __ ] popping but
your tolerance is gone but your brain
tells you you can drink like you used to
shoot that's when you end up in the ER
that's when you overdosed you get
alcohol poisoned her wound that's
exactly what happened Harrell ha I'm
happy you came on through to see you I
love you so much I made that [ __ ]
turn I go look at her this gym is
[ __ ] working look at me
he's all hypnotized what are you
supposed to think you walk out of here
leaves on the sail colors [ __ ] to me
Jesus Christ feel beautiful you read
some [ __ ] things fully as always on
it the [ __ ] leader of that life
listen man it's the holidays everybody's
looking at the change everybody's
looking to make their lives better you
know honor has some great supplements
for you that'll [ __ ] rock your world
from the hem force protein to the Alpha
brain just to get your mind going you
know go to on it calm right now press in
church CH you are CH and get 10% your
first order sent right to your
[ __ ] house right there no drama
and they also got no mood you're gonna
be traveling they have the alpha brain
packages that you put in the water and
it's not good and it helps you and
travel just a them not to get sick
alpha bound [ __ ] on it's got a ton of
[ __ ] this this what do you call this
supplement no podcast
transmission [ __ ] oils no I'm sorry
put on all fairness and stuff you want
to get started go 200 calm right now
press in charge and get 10% off your
first order enough with that [ __ ]
also you're going to be traveling this
season mm-hmm okay I don't really read a
lot of magazine believe twice to take
magazines I'm on the road if I read
anything I'll look at Rolling Stone just
the front to see who's going to who's
parties and little [ __ ] each other
but listen I know you're like magazines
like fitness fortune Forbes Golf
Magazine Golf Digest you know country
gardens Sports Illustrated Sports
Illustrated kids if you like any of
these magazines right now Town and
Country I got something that's gonna
rock your world all right now we're all
binge eating and we're all binge
watching him wall thanks to Netflix
we're all watching you know but now with
texture texture you can stop binge
reading trust me it's about to be a
thing I just saw a commercial for it the
other night you saw a commercial
protection so when it comes to magazines
you know what you like and with texting
you get all the magazines you want and
one super convenient place text chat has
completely reimagined reimaged
magazines giving you the articles and
stories you really want all in one place
plus interactive feat features videos
and recommendations just for you okay
the texture app lets you tap into the
world's most popular magazines
Anytime Anywhere using your smartphone
or tablet just download it you send a
plane and there you have hundreds of
your favorite magazines including black
back issues and pick the articles that
interest you the most texture has made
it easy to find articles that you care
about I don't I don't just read get the
you know rolling stone or Sports
Illustrated the text editorial team
recommends content for me every day plus
I can dive deeper with personalized
collections so you have like you're
ready right okay
you're like a curator that's cool yeah
they'll give you special things that
they think you'll like based on what
you're reading there you go so Senate
protection right now and gain inside
access to all the content from the
world's best publications the best part
is texture for the holidays is offering
a free trial right now when you go to
texture comm slash Joey again you'll
gain immediate entry into all the top
magazines including back issues and
bonus video start binge reading for free
right now when you go to texture dot-com
slash Joey again texture comm slash Joey
listen we talked about the holidays
coming and we talked about stuffing we
call those things a stocking stuffer
stocking stuffers there you go plain is
[ __ ] simple hello
tushy calm you know why because bidets
are back you want to start off 2017 with
a fresh [ __ ] [ __ ] and a
fresh [ __ ] and that's that
totally the content of [ __ ] world ok
and hello pushy has made that possible
again because the days are back you're
sitting there going Joey I'm a young kid
what's a bad day every day it's a device
that sprays your butt clean with water
ok I grew up with a bidet in my house my
mom had one [ __ ] tremendous eye after
she died and then I realized what they
really did and now they're back ok
thanks to tushy sleep the day that clips
on the existing toilet and sprays your
butt completely clean with fresh water
to get your muffler sparkling so you're
not sitting on it all [ __ ] day with
bacteria and then causing hemorrhoids
and yeast infections and plain old just
rotten ass why do you know who wants
rotten [ __ ] aspirin Chris but days
are better for the environment because
there's more paper that means more trees
every time every time you use a bidet
it's one point of water
that ain't dick ok
she stands behind their product also for
60 [ __ ] days so you can enjoy
it you see what the hell it is
tremendous I'm using that I got a nice
bed better bathroom now [ __ ]
tremendous do you understand me it's
been years
the water's nice and cold it kind of
wakes you up in the morning after that
coffee's gonna let me take a little
[ __ ] dump irui oh you put cold water
calm right now and get 10% off when you
press in church CH you are CH taking it
to the hill like a [ __ ] this is
the Christmas present for Ike right now
you're sitting at this guy what am I
gonna get this girl what am I gonna get
this guy what am I gonna get this guy
uncle Joey just brought it to you right
now hello Toshi calm call / Church get
10% off I want to thank texture I want
to thank Allah doctrine for being solid
[ __ ] if you haven't watched the
special see so calm
/ Joey put your name and email code put
your credit card in put in Joey and you
get the watch the [ __ ] special for
free don't say I never gave you that and
when you get bored they got all the
Saturday Night Live [ __ ] episodes
they got Parks and Recreation on
original programming so go do your thing
all right I'll see you [ __ ] next
week anyway these people could find you
elicitation yeah on Twitter and
Instagram at the Andrea Lowell if you're
interested in anything Fitness related
Facebook and Instagram at Andrea Lowell
fitness pretty straight forward Lee what
do you got going on this weekend this
weekend
and not much as we can but I had I had
an outsider breakfast with my brother
today for the first time we don't
haven't been speaking for years so oh
really
yeah that was nice so that's good you
didn't break any zip lines talk to your
brother sounds like a pretty [ __ ]
successful day so yeah it was a pretty
good yeah I love how we'd hardly know
each other I'm already like teasing you
I like it he likes it I like it too who
wouldn't like it well that's cool I'm
happy for you guys yeah it was fun
and that's like waiting for the punch
and then what happened I live a boring
life
what did you have for breakfast I stay
in the dirtiest way you can scrambled
eggs mmm where they runny or where they
dry dry like like palm fronds I love you
thank you happy holidays look I have to
pee so [ __ ] bad
[Music]
you
you
you